Alright guys, so here's another example. You can see that we were creating
Lorelo, LoreHi, Lorelo, LoreHi, and then we created this last Lorelo.
During the launch break, as you can see, the London session was over. Sorry, the Asian session
was over at this candle, right? So this next candle, it just swept the low
of the Asian session, and then we had a market structure shift, which is right here,
or change of character, whatever you want to call it. And then we were left with this
imbalance and autoblock, so let me mark this out. As you can see, we marked this autoblock out,
and this was a perfect, and I mean perfect entry. Our store plus would probably go here,
below this low, or around here, and as usual, we will target the high of the Asian
range, and as you can see, this was a 6.22 restore wall trade, and as you can see, how perfectly
price reverses then. So this is the best place to take your profits, and let me give you a few more
examples before we move on to the next strategy.